In your opinion, what is Brady?
It's like a graph, or connected circuits?
No, this is an ant. You can see the horns of the sensor here, then this is the body of the ant
AHA OK
We will place a place for consecutive individual integers starting with this ant
So, what are these individual integers that begin with one?
Well, we need one, three, five, seven, nine
We'll put them here
So, what number do you want here?
Seven
Seven, here?
three
And here?
One
Let's put nine
And ?
five
Well, this is an example of failure
We'll look at five minus one. Equals four
Eight minus one equals eight, three minus one equals two
Everything looks different and looks good so far
It is regrettable that seven minus three also equals four
So our failure is an example of failure, your task is trying to make all these differences different
If you put seven three and one nine five
Then we will have four and eight
And six
And four. Oh wait no This is still a disaster, I wonder if this is even possible to fix the Ant for the most difficult to fail
But I'm supposed to be successful here, okay
Let's start, nine, one
No, maybe I'll put seven on top
Here, five here and three here, will this result?
Yes this sounds good so this is nine minus one equals eight, seven minus one
Equals six
Four and two
All are different
We managed to reach the end
So this is part of a problem that has not been resolved since 1967
The tree is called graceful but belongs to all primary school curricula
Each time they learn the proposition, so the general problem is given any number of connected circuits
So that bind is needed
Any number you want to be connected to can be rings so it would be a minute insect to solve
Let me show you an episode that you can ask to solve so that it can be solved or may not be resolved
But it is certainly not an attractive guess of trees, the graceful tree guess is that there are no rings, right?
Well, but why not try to solve this so we need one three five seven
And nine in 2 and 2 here can be solved
Considering the number of even numbers you can get, what is the largest number you can get as a difference between them?
Eight, nine, and one, the biggest you can get is eight
What is the second largest number you can get? Six Yes
The third largest number four and then the last number is two only exists
There are four different numbers you can get but how many lines do we have to achieve
Our five lines have only 4 pairs to be distributed among these five lines
So regardless of how to distribute
These are individual numbers
You'll end up with a duplicate so we have eight six four two
And four again
We ended up with repetition here
So that this starfish can not be solved it will fail every time if we have n circles and n lines that connect them
We will not be able to solve this, maybe we can solve M circuits
In this case five circles are n minus one
Maximum of four lines
We can sometimes solve that, with five circles where you can solve it, you have a butterfly shape
There are at least five lines and one connector, so this can be solved
Five circuits and four connectors, do not know if this can be solved but may be able to resolve the intuitive agile tree
Without including episodes, but this is still
An interesting question I do not know is solving this. So the graceful tree intuition is one of the places where all your circles link
If you do not have values ​​outside here and there are no loops
So that is guaranteed if you have got n circles you will have n minus one links
So here we have one two three four five six circles, one two three four five six lines
This is not resolved whether n is four circles
And n minus 1 lines
Where there are no rings
You can always put
Individual cascading integers are there
So that the difference between
All the circuits connected to all those differences are different
Unless it is certainly confirmed and intended for the old designs of the graceful tree
Oh yes to everyone
Insects or all the trees that are interested in its design, so this question has been solved by designing seven circles and this is an example
On seven circuits and six connected lines, there are already 11 different ways you can do
As well as here we have 11 different ways to make all seven circles
Connected without loops
What is not resolved?
Go for more circles if you draw
30 or 40 departments
Are all these solvable?
This was an open guess since 1967.
To what number of circles have been resolved?
There are individual cases that have been resolved, for example: I can put the circle in the middle and I can add any number
Of the overseas circuits you want
And this is always solvable and I can easily prove that I can put one number in the middle and then move to three five seven nine eleven thirteen fifteen seventeen twenty one twenty-three
You can imagine that I can stay here and this is always solvable, because these differences are always different. I can also put
The largest number in the middle of twenty-three can be in the middle and then I can distribute
Other numbers everywhere are solvable Another example: Another example of a species that can always be solved
Are snakes so you can imagine a snake of any length you want
These are always solvable you may want to try and you can start with one
And then you can go to the biggest one I'll just take and I'll move on to one three
Five seven and then I will return nine
Eleven Thirteen
Here, we have teams
Of twelve teams of ten teams of eight
Teams of six teams of four and teams of two
All snakes can be solvable only by repeating this pattern there are so many species out there
Not all of them are a snake to be assembled by the starfish
There are so many species that you can easily create and explore new species for example what happens if we have
A crazy thing you know about marine stars that have joined the long, long chain
If you can imagine for a solution that these can be very complicated very quickly
Most species have up to forty circuits for most of those insects
Very difficult to solve, supposed to be good if this question is still unanswered
This means that there is still a type of tree found to be definitely insoluble
Because that would ruin it, that's right
We did not find an example that did not work, but that does not mean it does not exist
There are many mathematicians who believe
That tree exists that there is a tree that can not be solved. Would you be happy or sad if it is found solved?
I would be thrilled to have found it solved because I do this with primary school children
After a week of struggle to find the solution I love to say
We found it!
But it seems
As if nature tells us that it can always be solved as if it looks like
Something nice as it looks like it will break something nice
Well, it has already been broken if you look beyond the intuitive tree to make the rings available
So we have seven circles
Six connectors so that these connectors can not be broken in a way that is already broken but interesting
That work with types that fail with the types
I love that .
Translation: شوان حميد Twitter: shwan_hamid @